predictions could become a harsh reality
as the state and cdc moratoriums are
soon set to end
thank you so much for joining us tonight
at 11 o'clock i'm sasha loftis
madison kimbra joins us live now with
what clark county leaders are doing to
help keep a roof over your head
madison yeah sasha this new program is
called the southern nevada eviction
prevention program
and it connects several different
resources for tenants and landlords in
need of help
during this tough time eviction
is a very sensitive and can be in a very
emotionally charged issue
thousands of southern nevadans are
struggling as they know the possibility
of eviction is near
governor steve sisilak's eviction
moratorium expires at the end of the
month
and the cdc's eviction moratorium
expires on july 1st
but now local leaders have come up with
a new program that would help these
tenants stay in their homes
to see a thoughtful plan come together
that links tenants with rental
assistance
and links them with mediation is very
very
encouraging as we see the moratorium
left it's called the southern nevada
eviction prevention program
the program has a variety of resources
for tenants and landlords to use
while figuring out their next step
assistant county manager kevin schiller
says multiple agencies are joining
efforts
what this will allow for is a connection
point between mediators
the chap rental assistance program and
clark county
in conjunction with the courts there are
steps nevadans facing eviction can take
during the following weeks and months
step number one a tenant needs
to if they are eligible sign a cdc
declaration
and give it to their landlord step two
a tenant needs to apply for rental
assistance
through the chap program step three
if a tenant gets an eviction notice the
tenant
absolutely must file an answer with the
justice court
step four when the tenant files that
answer with the court
the tenant needs to elect mediation
currently there is about 160 million
dollars available for rental assistance
which is expected to be enough to help
40 000 households
and landlords who participate in the
eviction prevention program
will receive the rent owed to them but
there are stipulations in which they
must follow in order to do so
reporting in the studio madison
kimbrough 8 news now